welcome back to mlst today we're
exploring the Innovative world of
artificial intelligence in search
technology with perplexity AI which is a
groundbreaking startup that's making
waves in the conversational search space
we also have the opportunity to
interview the co-founder and CEO Dr
aravind srinivas to learn more about
this remarkable technology and the
driving force behind it perplexity AI
despite being a relatively small starter
has managed to create a powerful and
reliable search engine with a mere three
million dollars in funding
they've achieved impressive results in
citation recall which was highlighted by
a recent Stanford study titled
evaluating verifiability and generative
search engines
the study found that perplexity AI
search engine provided comprehensive and
accurate citations ensuring that the
information that users received is
trustworthy and verifiable this
achievement is a testament to the
dedication and expertise of the team
which focuses on execution quality and
speed
perplexity ai's impact on users is
evident by some of the inspiring stories
shared by its customers I mean there was
one user in particular who's been
researching Foods helpful for late stage
prostate cancer found that perplexity AI
was an invaluable resource due to its
reliable citations
the user even reported a reduction in
the amount of cancer in their body
showcasing the profound impact that
perplexity AI can actually have on
people's lives now let's introduce
aravin srinivas the CEO and co-founder
of perplexity AI
aravind has an impressive background in
Ai and technology and some may even
remember that he was the second ever
guest on mlst at the very beginning
he's got a dual degree in electrical
engineering from the Indian Institute of
Technology and a PhD in computer science
from UC Berkeley aravind has interned at
leading organizations like deepmind and
Google and he's worked as a research
scientist at open AI focusing on
language and diffusion generative models
in 2022 he co-founded perplexity AI with
the goal of creating an impactful and
reliable conversational search engine
which can transform the way that we
access and process information
also there's some really exciting news
today not only has perplexity just
dropped gpt4 support so you can click on
the enhanced option in their menu they
have also announced a partnership with
wolf from alpha so you can go on there
and you can select Wolfram Alpha and you
can with the language describe anything
you want to do it'll be converted into a
Wolfram Alpha representation and then
you see the results back in symbols text
and images so please folks check this
out this is amazingly cool
um funnily enough I signed up for the
um you know the plugins feature on
chatgpt about a month ago or even more
than a month ago and I've still not got
access to it whereas right now you can
do it on perplexity so what are you
waiting for go and check it out
so we're incredibly excited to have
aravin join us today to share more about
the Journey of perplexity AI
the technology powering the search
engine and their vision for the future
of AI driven search engines so let's
welcome Dr aravind srinivas enjoy
aravind is an absolute honor to welcome
you to mlsd of course we've already
introduced you but tell tell the
audience what are you all about and and
tell us about perplexity
thank you Tim for having me here
I'm the co-founder and CEO of this
company called perplexity AI it's a new
startup that we founded last year in
September
and our mission is to build the world's
most knowledge-centric platform for
learning especially centered around
question and question answering so we
built the world's first answer engine if
you may call it that where you directly
get your answers to questions rather
than seeing a bunch of links
so imagine Chad GPT which is obviously
the raise right now but I can back up
what it says by citing relevant links so
that's what we put out to the world in
December last year
and we made it conversational in January
and we kept following it up with more
product features like Chrome extensions
and IOS app
and
Wikipedia like user interface and so on
so it's sort of evolved into this sort
of knowledge Hub that people go to for
learning more about things and sharing
what they learned with other people and
our mission is to expand that more and
more and be the world's most knowledge
Central company eventually
so I've been using your IOS app and I
think it's absolutely amazing and one
thing to sketch out is we've already had
access to Google for 20 years so it's
not like the information isn't out there
but there's something really interesting
about removing that extra bit of
friction
yeah
so Google is probably the world's most
complicated software product ever built
if you think about it
the amount of customization they do per
query
if you ask like about Tim scarf but you
can ask about like the live score in a
sports game
or you can ask news about Elon Musk all
of it goes through the same search bar
but the way the results are rendered is
so different for each query
and it all happens in milliseconds it's
pretty insane that a system like that
has been built so all created to them
for taking this mission that they have
of you know making information
universally accessible and useful
for the last 20 years
whoever
in the business interests
they've started throwing more ads in
most of the searches now in fact there
is a joke that the bigger the font size
of ads on Google the more Revenue they
make in a quarter
like historically
uh in the beginning they had no ads and
then they started showing it on the side
in small font and slowly the small font
uh started appearing right below the
search bar rather than on the side
and then the font of the ads became as
big as the search results and now like
for most queries
the first five links are sponsored links
and then the bottom five links are
sponsored link since your results are
somewhere in between and you kind of
have to sift through and find out what
you really want
that's not the purpose of a search
engine right ultimately the
the real mission is to just deliver the
answer to the user the user came to your
platform to learn about something and
your goal is to serve the user's need
and otherwise your business interests
are not the user's interests
and so in the long term you can only
build a successful company if you are
completely aligned with the user you may
not be aligned with the shareholders in
the short term but
eventually they will align so we took a
different perspective here we thought
like Okay Google's amazing but
um gone is the era of clicking and
sifting through links and finding out
what you really want from reading them
um and then
a powerful tool emerged last year
towards the end
in the form of chat GPT or GPD 3.5 if
you may call it that way
that has this amazing ability to
understand text and
really carry out your tasks
in natural language
and we thought we could combine the best
of that with the best of search engines
marry them together in the most
ideal way complementary way
to create this unique user experience in
the UI
that just gives you the answer also
gives you a few links if you want to
read them and make sure what we're
saying is correct
but not more than three to five links
and that already made a lot of people's
experience like so much better they were
like oh man like I don't have to look
through this clutter it's not that
people stop clicking on links they're
like some still like a lot of people
click on the links we serve
it's just that like somehow
they feel like they've been suffocated
in a room with like hardly any oxygen
and then they got this fresh air
where there's so much decluttered UI and
directly ingesting answers and making
the process of asking questions even
more fun and making the process of
learning even more fun
and so that that's actually why we as a
startup are able to like grow really
fast because people really wanted this
and we were at the right time to provide
this to them
yeah the learning things interesting so
I think large language models they have
a simultaneous effect of making you more
lazy but also giving you mental capacity
to focus on things and have a depth that
you would normally never even imagine
but I wanted to go back quickly because
you were talking about the advertising
and when when folks go to perplexity and
I've been using it all the time it's
amazing so it completely personalizes
the search experience and what it does
is it kind of virtualizes over all of
that structure and information that you
would otherwise need to hold in your
mind but I guess like there's a couple
of risks to that so one thing I wanted
to ask you is about if you did introduce
something like advertising how might you
do it
yeah I think this is a pretty
interesting question so I think
advertising is not like an evil thing uh
you know we
we do want to add sometimes like we are
it really depends on the intent of the
query
like if you are looking for the best
sneakers to wear for running
uh you are actually looking to buy
something or at least looking to gather
enough information to buy something
and so then you need to get links
relevant to a merchant who's trying to
sell on your platform
so those things are pretty relevant for
ads
so you kind of have to really figure out
like which queries really need these
sponsored links and which do not
and
I I come from an academic background
um and so one thing I've noticed people
do in research papers is
two kinds of citations one citation is
where the work really influences your
work
and so that's often cited in the
introduction and related work and things
like that and other kinds of citations
are sort of like mentioned citations say
like you know oh yeah these people have
also done it
um so that just you don't piss some
people off like you know you just make
sure everyone's giving you credit even
though that paper may not be as
impactful
and some citations suggest not even
mention citations like they're just
there in the paper right
uh and so you can sort of think about
links in the citation ERA with answering
similar categories like really relevant
links that should not be influenced by
people paying for getting cited
and then some links that are not like
super relevant but you can still cite
them or add as additional context like
if we have this thing called like you
know detailed and concise so we can have
some more toggles that are saying like
additional context and like there you
can sort of pay for getting displayed
there but it should be at the pop
interest of the user to see that and not
like
put right in front of their face or
something
and
I think only one consumer product I use
has really gotten ads right
Instagram
like I don't find it very you know
distracting in fact it's actually
pretty relevant so when the ads are
super relevant you might actually enjoy
them
uh like if you've seen been seen travel
reels about like say Switzerland or
something and you see a lot about more
ads related to that that's kind of nice
you actually might want to see that
right so uh
so if you kind of nail relevance which
is where llms can even help even more
because they understand the true
relevance even better than just clicking
data
I think you can get the ads experience
even better than what currently exists
on Google
yeah so I want to get to the relevance
but just to um rewind a tiny bit so yeah
chat GPT it was a significantly smaller
model but because of the way it was
trained with this instructor tuning
um It produced results which are very
much in the the style that we would
recognize as being relevant and and
useful yeah I want I want to talk about
the relevance thing which is um
right now when you go on Google they
have this page rank system and it's not
just pagerank they look at the number of
clicks and they do a whole bunch of
stuff but it's kind of like one level of
virtualization so you have some
intuition on how the relevance ranking
works yeah and and then when we do stuff
like this retrieval augmented generation
so we put a query in we go to a search
engine we inject all of that information
into the prompt and then we produce
relevant results and the results that we
inject in
um I don't know whether whether there's
some principled way of doing that but I
I guess I'm saying when you when you
have two levels of virtualization it's
no longer as intelligible to the user
which information is being prioritized
yeah
um actually that's a good question there
um one thing I'm proud about what we did
at perplexity is we
uh display the links in the sources
panel and if you actually expand it
the specific text that was used from the
links for the llm prompt is also shown
to the user
for the interpretability aspect
so you could imagine doing something
like that even for ads so that it's even
more transparent process than who's
bidding the most
uh currently on Google my understanding
the way it works is there's two
mechanisms one is the cost per click and
the other is cost per view
and for each of these there's a bidding
price
based on the frequency of the keyword
and these advertisers go and bid on
these keywords and phrases
and some pay for being clicked and some
pay for just being viewed and the system
sort of takes both these prices and
uh
uses the data of like how many people
are clicking on that particular
advertisers link and figures out a way
to boost them up and search results
relevant to those keywords so if you pay
a lot for getting clicked but nobody
clicks on you then the system penalizes
you but like you kind of have to end up
getting paid more but if you're already
getting
viewed a lot with a relevance algorithm
then you don't have to pay as much or
something it's a little bit it's more of
a complicated system that uh merges two
incentives which are
are which is sort of against each other
one is like paying a lot to get clicked
and the other is making sure you show
what's relevant
on the other hand with an llm you can
actually make all this pretty
transparent
uh by showing exactly the snippet that
was used in the relevance ranking so the
user can understand like why a certain
link got popped up because they can
actually look at the snippet that was
used
and we could even ask the advertiser to
write a natural language a rationale for
why they need to get cited
and
that could also be used in The Prompt
right
when you do the retrieval augmented
generation do you indicate to the
language model what the relevance was on
the underlying search index or is it
kind of like um these results will have
equal weighting
um
I think we don't do not do that right
now but that's that's an interesting
idea
uh
yeah for example um yeah I tried Bing
GPT and when you ask it about me there's
an old website that I haven't updated in
about five years and that says I've got
a different job title and it kind of
mixes that in because it doesn't seem to
realize that well LinkedIn is obviously
up to date and authoritative so why is
it why is that information on a Level
Playing Field
yeah so I think this is complicated
right like for example that's the case
for you
um for some other user they might not
have updated their LinkedIn in a while
but they might keep their personal
website pretty up to date
um
like I can give you an example like
Andre karpathy
uh for a while did not even update as
LinkedIn I don't even know if it's up to
date yet in terms of whether he's
currently working at open EI or not
uh but he updated his website to saying
he's a farmer teslaughter by the
director
and so now like for dim scarf it's
different but like for Android it's
different right like and then both are
pretty famous people so you can't say
like one thing is more important than
the other so the way I see it is like
allow the user to sort of edit these
things and publish things too
uh which is why we added this feature to
edit sources you can remove some sources
that you think as old or corrupting the
result and then you can
uh save that and like we're going to add
options for users to publish some
queries and then that can get indexed by
a search engine and that can get cited
by perplexity in a sort of recursive a
right and and so that's already
happening a little bit uh but we kind of
want to explore those kind of options
where the user
can naturally use the product and that
way let us know like which link is more
relevant to a query on a query by query
basis rather than like a
macro level okay this domain is more
important than the other and I'm going
to tell them
because that's like a bigger decision to
make right sort of like a decision that
we're kind of making as a information
service provider that like one domain is
more important than the other and those
are hard decisions and I also don't want
to be making those decisions personally
but uh because like you know like you
could say at a level about like journals
like New York Times more important than
Wall Street Journal or like Forbes or
Fortune which one do you really trust in
terms of the information that's coming
from each of these sites and what if
they have different views so the same
thing
and you kind of want to like Channel
thing rather than making a decision of
like who you want a channel
interesting so I wondered if there are
any challenges or opportunities around
this new modality right so rather than
the traditional user interface like on
Google where everything is segmented out
in a way that's quite good because if
you're doing attention metadata
advertising clicking and so on you
you've got everything represented as an
entity whereas now we have text and so I
think first of all from an advertising
point of view people might find it a bit
creepy if advertising is injected into
the text but similarly If part of the
text specifically is a problem at the
moment it's just a block of text but
maybe the next step would be to
automatically segment the text into
segments and then give me the
opportunity to say well that particular
thing is not relevant for what I've said
and kind of hook that back into the
learning process
yeah
I think we want to do something like
this obviously uh the right UI needs to
be figured out where
it's sort of interesting right what
you're saying is sort of
um
blurring the boundaries between a text
editor
and a search UI where you're just
consuming information on the second and
you're sort of editing and
iterating information on the first
and we're already sort of doing that in
some sense where you can remove some
links and things like that edit editing
the queries and curating them in your
repository of past threads so we're more
already like a draw box or notion kind
of interface than just typical Google so
that's already new this is all happening
because of the power of llms and like
earlier you had this sort of rigid
interface where the retrieval engine and
the ranking and it's just giving you a
bunch of links right there's no edits
that you can perform on top of the
existing UI
um so I think we I think your idea of
like even going more granular where you
can even like change parts of the
Snippets that you think are more
relevant to things like that would be
more interesting obviously if you don't
want to make the user work so hard to
get the answer
part of the job of the AI is to like
minimize the work for the user so that
user is just consuming and learning
stuff pretty quickly
but there's this aspect of viewing it as
a co-pilot for learning
where yeah you're like
working together with the perplexity Ai
and then
quickly getting up to speed on things
but they're okay to put in some amount
of work
to get to the answer and earlier that
work would be opening 10 tabs on Chrome
and reading through all the links and so
on
and now the work may be more like
uh uh like sort of like search as if it
was programming right like taking a
bunch of texts from different links and
like highlighting what you want and so
on and the UI has to really be so good
that you enjoy it rather than it being
conversion and that's why I feel like
it's it's an amazing product and a
platform to build and then I I also
wanted to be such that if you didn't put
put in the effort to do this
for the same query somebody might ask in
future like
um they shouldn't have to do it they can
benefit from the work you've already
done and if there's a way to reward you
for that that would be great uh
Wikipedia has this sort of system in
place where you know like the edits
probably one user is benefiting the
article being read by another user after
that
but there's no monetary reward people
are doing it for the non-profit mission
um if there's a way to sort of inject
some capitalism into this but retain the
truth Centric incentives that are
fundamentally core to the platform then
that'd be great and we want to kind of
figure that out
yeah and we'll move to the to the truth
bit next but the the one other thing I
wanted to comment on which you're
touching on now which is most exciting
to me is that um perplexity has as a
first class the trajectory of the search
and Discovery process and what I mean by
that maybe we should start off by
describing what Google does Google is
basically stateless apart from the page
that you're on and this is the reason
why people tend to have a hundred Google
tabs open right because you search for
one thing and you open it in a new
window and then in your brain you've got
a kind of like Marshal all this
information okay well now I've got this
tree and I'm one step down in perplexity
you do the whole thing in a in a
personalized interface and also you you
marry search and Discovery so you start
off traversing and then you suggest
potential you know new routes of
traversal and the way that your
algorithm learns is with traversal as a
first-class citizen so you're actually
saying that was an interesting traversal
that's not an interesting traversal so
the system gets better and better over
time time so I think that's probably the
most exciting thing from a learning
perspective because it's completely
personalized to me yeah yeah we we used
to think about this in the company as a
dynamic personalized Wikipedia for
everybody
um as a kid I love Wikipedia I think
most nerds love Wikipedia as kids they
probably still do and we all have this
thing of going to Wikipedia rabbit holes
where we start on a page and then we
keep blinking on the hyperlinks and it
keeps opening up new tabs and we're just
like oh like I was just two hours on
Wikipedia it used to be the tick tock
for nerds I guess uh and then
um so I really wanted to bring that sort
of experience perplexity we as a team we
really wanted to do that and um
and that's sort of why we made so many
good product decisions around like
suggesting good follow-up questions uh
making sure that the answers have
hyperlinks and some entities and you can
just click on them and they'll be
contextualized in the context of your
previous queries sound like giving you a
separate answer for the new entity
and that sort of gives you this
engagement Loop of asking more and more
and in fact like we
uh the first we launched we inhibited
only had the support for one query
and then we shipped the conversational
thing and that let people ask follow-ups
and then a percentage of threads that
would go into a follow-up was pretty low
like 20 maybe
but then once we ship more and more
features like adding related questions
follow-up suggestions and like entity
links in the answer that percentage is
shot up to 40 percent
so
it was pretty clear that if you made the
process of asking a follow-up even
easier for the user
the user enjoys like learning more and
like my own experience on the platform
right now like yesterday I was kind of
trying to learn more about companies
um just like how Venture debt financing
Works Equity financing works and which
companies have done it in the past and
things like that and like I just
realized my thread was like 25 questions
it was pretty insane like you know like
this sort of experience just wouldn't
exist advice and if you were to do
Wikipedia then you would have to open
all these different tabs and it's just
one article written for everybody
whereas here it's like personalized to
what you really want to learn so it sort
of allows you to zoom in and learn more
at A fine grain detail but also zoom out
and come at a macro level and connect
dots across like bigger picture things
and it's amazing in terms of like
learning so fast right
so that's the experience we wanted to
provide
yeah it's and I mean in a way we learned
a similar lesson from Instagram so in
when you when you're developing an app
every single bit of friction is
attrition so you make something easy
because it's not like I didn't think it
was that difficult to do research before
but it's a lack of imagination because
we didn't know anything better so now
you have this system where people can
click and click and click it's extremely
pedagogical and they can and they can
learn about things and it's remarkable
actually that just a small change could
could lead to such a dramatic difference
in in how people learn and consume
information but um I wanted to get to
the whole concept of objective truth and
and related topics so I guess one one
take would be oh I want to create a
personalized Wikipedia which only gives
objective facts about the world but is
that too ambitious and would that even
work
I think it's very ambitious uh firstly
Wikipedia is not a source of truth
either
um
by the way the the whole language model
Revolution was kicked off with uh
Wikipedia right like Wikipedia is a big
reason why Bert was so good
and Bert was sort of the inflection
point in NLP for everybody to switch to
Transformers so to pre-train a lot of
data
and then it evolved with things like
common crawl and regret it and things
like that over time right so
I do think Wikipedia is probably the
most truthful platform if if you want to
give them the credit to that and that's
an amazing thing because even though
there are like opinions on how like
Wikipedia has all these weird kind of
edits that preserve certain kind of
opinions and things like that
it is still the most authoritative
source of knowledge on the internet uh
and a lot of the links that get cited on
Wikipedia are pretty high authoritative
sources of information
um
so
creating something that's a dynamic
personalized version of some such a good
platform
and maintaining the truthfulness aspect
is very hard
the reason truth is hard is because
fundamentally we don't know what is
truth ourselves right like it's it's an
iterative process like we think one day
that Kobe vaccines are essential and we
all go and get it then there are
research papers written on the harmful
effects of covert vaccines and then
um there's always this debate of like
whether getting covert is the best way
to getting immune to it versus actually
taking doses of vaccines and there's
always like a healthy debate of like oh
is it in the interest of the
um
vaccine providers to you know like keep
selling you that that right so and the
origins of the covert vaccine virus is
still like debated so all these things
are like Okay then if you are a
perplexity if you're if you're an answer
engine
what should you be doing here right like
you you should provide as many diverse
opinions as possible in the Fallen
citations
and leave it to the end user to sort of
learn and that's sort of your your job
sort of done there but a lot of the user
expects you to make that process also
even easier for you like that process of
going and reading all these articles and
then coming to conclusions of their own
like
ideally the AI should help them there
too right and so that's like an even
bigger challenge
like like sort of algorithmic Truth is a
very hard problem and I feel like it's
even beyond the scope of gpt4 right now
uh to to sort of figure out what is it
really the ultimate truth in something
when there's like so many different
opinions and research articles that have
like different conclusions and so on
and I feel like it's it's something we
can only truly solve with more progress
and
HEI
that is an llm that can sort of have
really long context Loop and keep
reasoning for itself and going back and
forth between two different conclusions
and trying to arrive at the right
conclusion by collecting more evidence
and so on
yeah I mean that there's there's two
things there I mean first of all one of
the reasons why Noam Chomsky doesn't
like language models is that he hates
probability and there are folks who are
causal determinists so you know Chomsky
thinks basically we should have a causal
deterministic model of the world and
they would argue that science is about
deduction it's not about prediction and
only when you have a deduction can you
generate new facts and knowledge and
verify information and so on that's what
all the go five people always used to
say the world is much more gnarly than
that unfortunately and and that's why
language models work so well but
um it does lead to the question of
whether theoretically whether it's ever
possible to get truthful information
from a language model and and also I
want to also steer a little bit towards
um should these models and should
perplexity be opinionated and that might
be a form of personalization so it might
be this person has these values these
interests these previous interactions is
it okay to be opinionated
yeah we've been thinking about this
actually I mean this is all relevant in
the context of the whole true GPT and
you know like trying to make sure that
the AIS are truthful
and
my opinion here is that
being politically correct is not very
well aligned with being truthful
I think we all agree to that actually
like there is a reason that
if someone's not politically correct
people like them more
maybe they don't like them personally if
they say things that they don't agree
with but they at least are interested in
listening to that person
um
and the sort of why people tend to like
always notice when Elon Musk speaks
maybe because he has these
um
opinions right like it's not maybe he's
wrong but he actually has opinions
and
recently I was reading something that
Mark Zuckerberg said which is like you
can only say meaningful things if what
you say and the opposite of that
opposite of what you say are both
you know
agreeable
like like there should be a fraction of
people who agree with what he's saying
that should be a fraction of people who
agree with the opposite of what you said
and that's when you actually have said
anything meaningful otherwise it's just
platitude right
if you're going to say something that's
just objectively true
that's not interesting to anybody
uh so
then it sort of comes down to like okay
what is the mission of an answer engine
is it to just sort of teach people facts
that are already true
then in that case opinion and a fact are
both the same so there's no problem
there
like if you're asking how like Equity
financing works like you just have to
explain us
you know how it is in a rulebook right
but if you're asking things that are not
fully understood yet
um
having an opinion is fine as long as it
doesn't spread misinformation
like
as long as users are clear that
this is an opinion and not a fact
and that has to be prefaced carefully
then then it's probably fine to have an
opinion and then it's pretty important
to make sure that your opinions are
uh possible possibly corrected by with
more evidence that users can add on the
platform
and if and so then it comes down to a
question of incentives like why do you
need house or no opinions like if you're
baking in a prompt to have certain
opinions
like what is a prompt you would bake in
right into the llm
um and so all these things are very
complicated and so
the simplest solution is to say oh yeah
I'm just gonna
channelize everyone's opinion and give
you the sort of a lawyer's answer
but that makes a product a little boring
also so actually I don't know we've I've
been thinking about all these and like
there's no good answer to truth or
opinions and stuff because your goals
sort of provide facts as well like this
whole range of queries where you just
have to like be correct because it's
already scientifically true or something
and um yeah I've been thinking about
this I I still don't have a good answer
yeah and when I play with gpt4 if you
get it to generate creative scripts for
example they're typically not very
creative they tend to kind of like go on
to railroads so they'll either sound
like a TED talk or they will sound very
formal and very dry and actually um when
we say someone has a Charisma bypass
it's because they sound formal and
that's how we're expected to behave in
in the office but as you say there's
there's something more than that and
there was that film The Social dilemma
where they were talking about the
success of of Facebook and a lot of that
is because of the echo Chambers and
because it deliberately fractionated
people into
um cohorts of subjective belief which
was their truth and that's very engaging
for people but I guess like perplexity
you almost need to kind of like there's
a real problem around misinformation so
so is it possible to have subjective
truth but also take a strong position on
misinformation
yeah I think we already took us from
Precision on misinformation like we are
not going to channelize any answer
without citations
and none of the cited links are written
by anybody in the company it's be
written by people in the world
and so people cannot accuse us of
misinformation because number one we
cite whatever we say and despite the
citation if we get a hallucination wrong
uh we have been transparent about
queries where we actually have
hallucinated
and that's actually why we took this
step to allow the user to remove certain
links that think is hallucinating the
answer
and we're also going to allow users to
add more links
themselves to add further context like
sort of community notes on Twitter
um
so I think we are trying our best to
make sure there is no way any shared
link on perplexity uh spreads
misinformation
um this is not the case with chat GPT by
the way like if you share a screenshot
chat if you teach somebody
who thinks AI is all knowing and it's
pretty good
uh it's very confidently bullshitting a
lot there in terms of what it says
mix up links makes up facts and it's
pretty convincing actually
so if you don't know much about that
area or topic you might even believe it
that's actually why we want our UI to be
also more popular like people should
want citations people should ask for
like okay no make sure this is actually
reasonably correct
and um my feeling is that there'll be a
bifurcation in the market in terms of
people wanting for open-ended creative
made-up stuff just for the entertainment
aspect and or or writing tasks and
things like that and then people wanting
just a source of knowledge and facts and
like that sort of like us
and
I think like the the market will sort of
bifurcate there in terms of you know
there's always like a like an
entertainment entertaining aspect of
creating deep fakes or fake stuff right
like as long as it doesn't
get misused and and then there's an
aspect of making sure you can go and
learn stuff like like you say you
Googled it like you want to make sure
what you read is correct and we are
focusing more on the second Market
yeah I mean people talk about the the
threat of large language models but as
you say there's going to be a plurality
of large language models so there will
be ones for different purposes because I
don't know whether you wanted to comment
on that but there was that recent AI
moratorium and I personally think that
this technology could revolutionize
Society especially around education but
with the misinformation there's an
education piece there's a transparency
piece we need to teach kids to have you
know skepticism to have an inquiring
mind we might need to develop technology
to detect if things are detected by
language models but you know you can't
uninvent something this is this is
happening now so what do you think we
need to do to embrace this new kind of
Digital Society
so I think that
uh
first of all I I actually think most of
the functionalities that people use
strategory for was available one year
ago right but in the form of the open AI
playground
assisted the accessibility to the
average person in the world
dramatically changed in the form of the
chatbot UI
um sure the charity is even better in
being human-like and carrying out the
conversations with arila chef and things
like that but
if you notice most of the screenshots
they're just like instruction prompts do
me this or correct me appointment the
style of this or something like that and
like that's
that was available one year ago like you
knew it if you're an AI and I knew it
um
so I I think that part has just
proliferated so so much and people are
getting scared for their jobs and people
are getting scared for homeworks and how
children are even gonna like have an
incentive to learn stuff
so I do think like releasing chat GPT or
GPT 4 was good in that sense because if
we took even longer
the gap between what is possible and
what people think was possible would
have just widened even more and then if
that Gap keeps widening more the fear of
the average person in the public would
increase
so the more frequent we are in releasing
things and communicating to people and
getting them up to speed
the water is actually possible in Ai and
educating them
uh that has
a positive effect in making sure that
the average public is not scared of AI
because when people are scared that's
paranoia and like all sorts of weird
things happen right
um so that's the the that's sort of my
argument for making sure we have these
frequent iterative deployments and keep
learning from what public thinks
uh that's it I'm all I I definitely
agree with you on the concerns about
like you know
impact on jobs and like future of
learning and like what kind of jobs
should kids even seek in future
um how would programming look like how
would writing look like and like what
happens to all the sales and marketing
people is any profession free uh like
like is the CEO job even free like if
you think about it like what does the
CEO do they just make decisions with all
the data available like if all that can
be
written clearly with
in natural language and fed into an llm
it can do all these things for you right
so
my thinking around this is it's a little
utopian
I feel like
the progress in llms will push all of us
to have ultimate Clarity of thought
like just like how using Google was a
skill Once Upon a Time talking to these
language models like they even call
these as language model Whisperers will
become a skill
and to make best use of them you
actually have to have really good
Clarity of thought
and and good taste in selecting the
right problems or the right completions
and things like that and so the the same
kind of professions will exist
um humans will find creative joint being
creative and like doing new things but
in order to be really successful at it
they need to be using these AI tools
and in order to make best use of these
AI tools they need to be really
clear in their head what they want out
of these tools
and that would push all of us to be very
good first principle thinkers and have
good Clarity of thought and that's
actually good for the planet because
that way people have more rationality in
them and do less bad things so that's
sort of my utopian view around it but I
I completely agree with you that it can
be used for political misinformation
like powerful moving speeches that can
antagonize like a section of the
population against each other and things
like that and we obviously need to be
able to detect if people are doing these
things
and yeah make sure we educate the public
about it
I mean that resonates a lot with me but
because it's so easy to generate rousing
speeches it's similar with air that the
value of it has almost gone down because
the the scarcity has gone down it's easy
to produce that kind of content yeah but
um I wondered whether you had an opinion
on I mean for example I use language
models all day every day and they are
quite complex beasts and they behave
differently in different situations and
I now Intuit that the information in the
context is very high resolution the more
grounded it is the less likely it is to
hallucinate with perplexity it's very
grounded it's grounded in actual search
results but I just wondered whether your
intention is to abstract away the inner
workings or kind of educate users on
when it works and when it doesn't work
um I think we want to educate them and
like we are trying our best even sure
telling people where it works well and
doesn't work well
um and we also think that the long tail
of cases where it doesn't work well will
slowly get like smaller and smaller as
models become more capable our index
becomes more rich
and we understand more from the failure
use case and address that through
engineering
um
yeah so so the only thing I would say is
perplexity is like sort of like this
educated Uncle kind of product right
like it the Persona is more like this
knowledgeable
person who's just gonna be
asked accurate or correct as possible
and
personas and interestingness might also
be an aspect of this like for example
we did this April Fool's joke of putting
out all the answers in the files like
Shakespearean poems or raps and people
complained about it saying like hey I'm
doing my homework like stop like wasting
my time because it was a weekend and
they were doing the homework using
perplexity
so you know like sometimes you might
think oh you kind of make the product
more interesting and have a persona
um
but then people come to your product for
a certain specific goal and like you
have to serve that right
yeah um because when I when I read books
um it's you know the experience is
enmeshed in the subject or experience
I'm having at the time I'm on the train
um I had certain social experiences I
went to London you know and my break
because obviously there's objective
information and you can distill it down
and you can personalize it and that's
all great but it's almost like you need
to have some subjective experience in
there to help people learn
yeah I I think there's some some some
aspect of leaving a mark on the mind of
the user
that wants them that makes them keep
coming back to it and like feeling a
sense of
like like happiness when using your
product or something like like if Kindle
was just a book like you know they do
these subtle things with the reading
time and like the Delight the level of
brightness on the screen and things like
that and I've listened to Jeff Bezos
speak about this like how like you know
they really wanted it to make it look
like an actual book even though it's a
digital device and like so that it
Kindles the memories of
you know new reading from the book
so I I do think like those kinds of
aspects we can work on in complexity too
um and we are going to try as much as
possible to make the process of learning
and asking questions fun but at
not at the cost of saying wrong things
yeah I mean from a user experience point
of view and there are little things like
the way you stream the text is is very
very cool things like the um the the
speech recognition is really cool in the
future maybe you could add like TTS in
in really really cool then all of these
things kind of like completely change
the way I comprehend and experience the
information
yeah completely I mean I I think
it's not just a TTS aspect but the whole
voice to voice thing if you're like
having your phone in your pocket and
you're walking and you're like talking
to somebody and you have your airpods on
and you just ask the hey perplexity like
you know what what is actually the
the secret behind like you know r or the
chef like I'm talking to a friend of
mine I don't completely understand it
and he wants me to explain it to
both of us and then like we just screen
the answer and like talk speaking in a
nice human likewise
that's that experience is just going to
be surreal right especially when it's
almost going to be right
and not going to be a
mouthful speaking like a huge paragraph
but like really concise answers
that's just going to be incredible and
like and if you want a more you just
keep asking more and and if the whole
thing works speech recognition DTS
and like the llm aspects all chained
together
that's literally like having
an incredibly knowledgeable professor in
your pocket or something right like it's
pretty insane and it's gonna be a game
changer yeah
well I can give an example I've been
using this app called read wise that
I've just discovered so I can click on
an article and then it's in my phone and
I was driving to the airport this
morning and I played the article with
TTS on the phone and I'm sure you've had
this experience when you're in the
shower or you're in the car and you
listen to an audio book and my my God
it's a completely different experience
you're not distracted you're in the Flow
State and imagine being able to just
have a conversation with your professor
in your pocket while you're in the car
yeah and and it could not just be a
professor but
could even be like some famous person
you admire
if it's sort of ingested everything that
have said in the internet and their
first and the biography and things like
that
um like I might want to have a
conversation with Larry Page it's like
the most elusive Tech CEO that nobody
knows anything about and then
if I have access to all the books that
have been written about him and all his
interviews that he's given in the 90s
and 2000s
in all the current context of what's
going on in the world I might just be
like hey Larry what do you actually
think about a chance PD you know how are
you gonna respond about it this is an
imaginary conversation but like I'm sure
people would love to have that and if it
can darken his voice back to me
that'd be even more incredible right and
uh
yeah I mean I I think all these things
are going to happen and like I'm super
excited about the possibilities to the
advances what's possible
and
yeah we should we should fear the bad
parts too I'm not saying only good can
be done here but there's so much good to
be done here that it's just exciting
yeah exactly and and also it's a little
bit like when DJs do mixes they're kind
of creating novelty right because when
you remix information you'll bring it's
not an old book anymore because you
might be representing it in a different
style you might be mixing in context or
stuff about that particular profile and
you're making things interesting and
engaging that wouldn't otherwise be
which is which is fascinating but um I
wanted just to move it a little bit to
some technical stuff so um first of all
like what are you thinking about the
future of language models and also do
you remember that lacoon recently put
that slide out where he said that these
exponentially diverging trajectories and
auto regressive models are doomed I mean
what do you think about that
yeah
um I mean he's not wrong I mean I I
don't think he's wrong machine learning
wise like he's just saying that if you
do Behavior clothing alone that'll be a
distribution mismatch between what you
trained on and what you tested because
um
there there will be the sort of uh
compounding errors problem that once you
get one action in the trajectory wrong
um and that drips you into a completely
different part of the state space and
then
you get more actions wrong and then you
get more action strong and they just
completely go off for him
um so that's
that's a fair argument the thing that
he's actually missing knows that
number one as we pre-train these models
on so much data
like trillions of tokens
the amount of if data efficiency you
gain for the behavior learning step
is this immense that like you actually
don't need that much data uh the
distribution will be covered with very
little data the estimates will be much
better
and there is this additional rohf step
that you can generate infinite data if
you have a good reward model
or anthropic's new constitutional AI
stuff that samples you know different
principles and has like not just one
scalar reward but
you know like several scalers that you
can create on the Fly
you're just basically creating infinite
data for free with the reward model
right
for trajectories and then you're doing
all relative so that's sort of like
doing the inverse RL step like you're
running a reward model and then
um updating your policy against it
and once these two things are done like
the compounding error problem is no
longer a problem
it's exactly how RL solves things like
obviously RL tries to maximize the
coverage of the state Space by
generating enough data for itself
and that's the advantage of using a
reward model you can just can generate
infinite data and once you have infinite
data like nothing is an actual problem
so that's my
comment on the lekin thing
and
yeah I I don't think Auto regressiveness
is a problem at all it applies to
any kind of generative model where like
you don't have sufficient data you know
data coverage basically
okay but maybe you could comment on the
performance of it so gpt4 for example is
amazing but especially if you run it
non-interactively you might be doing
reflection or Auto GPT or something like
that it's just really really slow do you
think the auto regressive thing in
particular because obviously you can't
parallelize it is is that slowing it
down
um I think you could maybe do block wise
you know like you could decode many
tokens at once and things like that
um
but but the auto gpt4 is slow for two
reasons right like one is just the size
of the model itself
it's probably a lot larger than 3.5
and um
so that's obviously going to be a lot of
computation whether it's Auto regressive
or not for every new thing you decode
but it's certainly exciting to think
about like non-auto regressive models or
like blocky Auto aggressive models and
things like that and um
as far as the specific comment about
Auto GPT itself
um
I think people will be willing to wait
for an output if the value of the output
is so high
like if you just ask somebody to go do
background research on
non-autoregressive generative models
because you Tim had no time to do that
yourself
and they came back to you one hour later
with such a lucid explanation of the
best techniques there and like what
really makes it work and what is causing
it to still
lag behind in terms of being
state-of-the-art compared to Auto
regressive models
you would like still liked it you would
be like okay fine I'm happy to wait for
once what you came up with is pretty
insane that saved me like 100 hours of
time so one hour I pay for is like worth
it I saved 99 hours too
and yeah
and I feel like Auto GPT kind of things
will
if it was sort of Usher that future
where you would basically just pay for
it with your time and you would even
like and if your time was worth so much
you would actually be willing to pay for
the software too
that well yeah I was going to go there
so um I've written some kind of
reflection type GPT forecast because I
realized I was using GPT and I was just
doing all of this mundane stuff there's
an error feed it back in there's an
error feed it back in and it gets better
over time because it has this kind of
emergent understanding there's something
really fascinating about iteration and
just watching the understanding emerge
over several steps but I don't want to
be the guy doing that interactively so
imagine if there was like a version of
perplexity where it knows that I'm
interested in a particular topic and it
can just spin off and do this research
and just reflect and reflect and
consolidate and refine and then it can
kind of present back this research to me
the next day
yeah I think we do need to build the
ultimate
research and knowledge assistant
and that's just going to make
see people hire these endless research
analysts for like hundreds of thousands
of dollars in hedge funds and you know
like Capital allocation funds
or like research assistants and a PhD
lab
just because the pi or the person
running that fund doesn't have time to
go and do all the work themselves
and that's going to become available in
the form of an on-demand software you
just pay like 10 or 20 dollars a month
that's crazy right think about it so I
think it's going to happen and when it
happens this is going to be insane and
the whole world has just become a lot
smarter uh it's sort of like what the
iPhone did
now you and I can use the same iPhone as
Elon Musk uh it doesn't matter like it's
just thousand to two thousand dollars
right so
imagine the same Powers brought for
intelligence like like IQ
anybody has access to the smartest
person on the planet
Elon has access to the smartest people
as Sam has access to the smartest people
because they can hire them to work at
open AI or Tesla or Twitter
but if all that is just available to
anybody in the world
where intelligence itself is
something that's commoditized
that's a crazy world we'll be living in
right and and then a starting point is
to like at least one aspect of
intelligence is to be able to research
anything and be able to distill what
you've learned into like something
concise and useful to the user in a
personalized way
and allow them to keep learning more
iteratively by asking you more and more
questions
and even work as an
SCI pilot and if you can if you make all
that like a science pilot where
you're like not just coming back after
one hour because that might be
unreliable but
you can come back frequently with like
saying hey this is what I learned like
can you help me more and like you you
give it more feedback along the way and
it learns and over time it has enough
feedback for so many users that it can
fill up these Chain of Thought itself
and reason for itself like all these
things are going to be possible very
soon and gpt4 will make it possible and
you should also prepare for a world
where gpt4 is much faster and cheaper
and things like that with the hardware
and other advances
and yeah I'm already Imagining the
world's going to get there and making my
decisions on like how we work on things
like perplexity based on that
yeah I'm thinking the whole world of
note taking will be revolutionized
because we'll all have our own personal
knowledge stories because in a way it
won't be so much going out to the
internet anymore my personal agent would
have already amassed my own personal
knowledge store and I'll be able to kind
of interrogate that directly through my
agent and and maybe not even go out to
the internet that often
yeah I hope so and yeah I hope like we
all have like a knowledge Hub and
it doesn't have to be on the cloud it
could be on our local device I mean
maybe it should be on the cloud first
you know security and
encryption and things like that but
um
I hope we don't have to go much to the
internet I hope we all have this power
of the internet packaged into a
quantized language model that just runs
on a very powerful local chip on our
device and then
allows us to just keep becoming smarter
and not waste much time that'll be
incredible
amazing well aravind it's been an
absolute honor to have you on the show
thank you so much for joining us thank
you Jim
cool right